here now to discuss the coronavirus in
more detail so much to get into CBS News
medical contributor dr. David agus I'm
gonna start with the question I think a
lot of people at home are wondering how
does this spread meaning how might I get
this because we're hearing about
community spread now not just direct
contact so what the problem with this
virus and why we're getting all excited
everyone says why are you so worried
about this it's not killing anybody near
the flu is that for two weeks you have
the virus you can spread it and you're
asymptomatic so the problem is you go to
a movie theater not knowing you have the
virus you cough once you can affect the
movie theater and so that's what we're
afraid of is the rise in cases going up
dramatically there are a few number of
kits in the United States doing testing
so we're seeing these four cases that
had no known contact with virus
individuals but we're testing almost
nobody so the number of cases is much
much higher we just haven't tested that
changing the testing are we going to see
more tests we certainly hope so I mean
the the CDC is going to release more
tests early next week they announced
yesterday they can allow hospitals to
develop their own tests because we are
sorely lacking on the testing front in
the United States right now in most
places around the world that's getting
worse but in China now it's actually
getting a little bit better well China
put in a quarantine that is awesome
right you cannot leave your house you
cannot go to school you cannot go to
work you cannot go to church quarantines
work we are going to have quarantine zin
the United States of America in the next
week or two it's not if but it's when
and where it will happen it'll be a new
way of life there's no panic we're all
going to be safe but this is how we're
going to control the virus from an
exponential spread you call this the new
normal
this is the new normal we're gonna have
a different way I mean you know we're no
longer gonna go like this anymore we're
gonna go like this we're not going to be
shaking hands we're not going to be
congregating in large group for several
months starting Monday the schools in
Japan the entire country are closed for
a month that is the new normal is online
education for kids and so we have to
look at it differently you know the
delivery man pretty soon that's going to
be a drone so nobody touches your
packages and we're not going to have
transmission of disease so I'm curious
you know in the real world out there
folks have all sorts of scenarios going
on in their head friends are coming to
visit from Italy and other countries are
we gonna see a clamp down
who might be able to enter this country
so there's a new policy nobody from
Italy is allowed in oh yeah yeah we're
gonna start to see policies like that is
that they're gonna be high-risk regions
that it's not just from other countries
it's here if San Francisco is on
quarantine we don't want people from San
Francisco to travel to Los Angeles and
we're gonna have a new normal you know
to do that so are there ways that we can
prevent the just the spread outside of
the quarantine I mean people are gonna
have to go out and sort of like grab a
bunch of groceries throw them into the
basement and live you know off of you
know what I mean let's take a step back
so about a third of coronavirus of colds
or coronaviruses it's a common virus
fact that picture that graphic right
here is amazing because in the 1960s
when they first identified corona virus
they saw those projections and they said
it look like a crown that's why it's
called corona and so this is a new
strain of them that is spread
dramatically but it causes lung
inflammation
most people get over fine 80% of people
have mild symptoms but the elderly
people who are tobacco smokers have a
much more aggressive course and that's
what we're worried about just to remind
people though if you're traveling if
you're out and about to Michelle's point
you mentioned this with use your elbow
what can people do to try to prevent any
bacteria any germs spread includes your
realm right or the equivalent alcohol
wipes they work the masks you know we
use the masks backwards masar if you're
going to COFF you coffin do your mass so
particles particles don't go in the air
it's not to protect you from viruses
which are small which can go through the
mass right if you are sick your child
has a runny nose you've got to stay even
if you don't know if it's grown does it
whatever it is you stay home now this is
we all have to protect not just
ourselves but our community I want to
change I mean I really think this is
gonna make community focus first a new
way of thinking very very quickly doctor
in seconds if a lot of people are
thinking about canceling vacation plans
whether it's a European vacation a
cruise should they do it like I'm a
debate it depends where it is and so all
of us just need to be aware we don't
know exactly what's going to happen the
month next month or two is critical so
everyone is saying should I travel do
not travel to a high-risk area other
areas it is fine to travel to now I am
flying home on you
I did to Los Angeles today and I am not
worried right doctor thank you very much